citizens of the reject Nation you
demanded it you asked for it you wanted
it now here we are with Jack Quaid
Superman my Adventures of Superman I
call it Jack Wade Superman I'm a little
biased you haven't seen it no I haven't
I binged it before you got here
he's gonna be looking at me like I look
at him with comic curve and just like
you know he's coming you know what's
coming I don't even know what uh story
lines they do I've been able to avoid
most of this in the internet uh I know
there's some moments that like you know
people have been like oh my God that
happened and I didn't click didn't click
so we were diving into my adventure with
Superman we're gonna be watching not one
not two not three but four Great Scott
that's a lot of Superman at once and
then discussing it at the end and then
we're gonna be doing the rest of the
series leading up to the finale on the
25th so stay tuned click this watch it
comment share it with your friends so we
keep on going and watch up to the finale
and faster than a speeding bullet are
the folks over at prepper who help us
shape who help us edit who help us make
this very program so much love to them
over if you want to watch this in its
entirety if you want to watch four
episodes of us watching it head on over
to patreon and become a super sexy
reject so you can see all of those super
sexy tights in real time and our resting
faces
as we dive into this show uh please
please let us know in the comments what
you want us to watch next we've been
enjoying the entire DC Animated Universe
and DC animated movie universe and
tomorrow versus in all their entireties
so uh let us know what you want us to
keep getting into without further Ado
let's adventure with Superman three two
one
it's the first 2023 thing I think we've
watched yeah what does it look like in
the Modern Age how do they animate today
[Music]
oh
no
a car in the intro that's right they're
doing it they know back to the classics
[Music]
oh my god oh careful
[Applause]
damn
[Music]
foreign
that was cute great opening
I love his little notebook scribble s
like the 90s like yeah when is the show
set well according to the yes yeah
whoa
[Music]
I mean I know there will be challenges
ahead but this is just so fun and lovely
just Joy I like the strings yeah the
score is very whimsical
you're just a regular kid from Kansas
man not special at all Defenders of a
normal Man part one
that's what I say every morning
oh that's my favorite starting line
that's so good it's today hi Mr White uh
okay Shake gently do not crush his hands
be normal today just be extraordinary
ordinary
thank you for calling me
Vicky Vale this is the story that'll
make you a real reporter you can do this
I can do this hi there after you
thanks see you in there big guy meet
cute cuted oh uh my name is Clark
I have the three dozen donuts you wanted
to take yes no see it's it's not all for
me but he gets the sprinkles
I'm just gonna leave before this gets
any worse goodbye forever
I'll fix the front door later oh my God
our first day of the Daily Planet you
nervous I am pumped it's Canton Olson
uncovering true wait uh Jimmy the fact
that aliens Walk Among Us oh no one
psychic stalker's from Germany
you need to be working for the world
Weekly News guys yeah different Networks
angry driver Mount Simonson base is the
inventory warehouse for experimental
military projects and a day ago they got
robbed the only Road out leads through
Metropolis oh ready for me to bust the
story wide open oh Lois you're an intern
to meet them hi
you you oh find the robots and get the
story what are we waiting around here
for
uh donut Mr White
look at this little squiggle mouth
you like her as professionals
professionals come on Kansas take a risk
what's the worst that could happen I'm
about to find out angry drivers and
trash trucks every buyer fixer or fence
in Metropolis has just disappeared on us
we can't just sit in a warehouse full of
freaky stolen science weapon still the
cops show up
you can find a way out of town
[Music]
Gundam Superman
which one of you messed with the robot
[Laughter]
kid newspaper yes
Gabby does the op-ed Patty does the
cartoons yes only because Mom says we
have to be nice to her
in the last 24 hours a water main burst
at the bank Mrs Jurgens
Gabby saw a bunch of trucks running a
red light and I saw a weird pigeon it
was gross the trucks the trucks were
they garbage trucks yeah why
if I had to transport stolen goods
through the city I'd find a way to do it
in plain sight yeah and where exactly
did you see them disappear what is this
paper in front of me where's the GPS I'm
a kid in 2023 with a newspaper and a map
Thomas guide
are you sure that Mr White is okay with
us following this
space
[Laughter]
it's my size you can definitely
[Music]
geez are you okay
yeah I'm guys look huh that's my figure
skating over here Dirty Dancing the
robot should be here look
look to be something look
p.m paranormal medicine yes must be that
Port of metropolis
they're moving the robots to the docks
come on we can catch them and then Harry
just called you lied I mean technically
you yes oh I trusted you and you used me
and Jimmy just so you could get your
story oh I don't need your help anyway
oh
Jimmy stands for sucker yeah but you
made me Lois fired from his dream job
all to chase a bunch of robots that
might not even be in the city anymore
Lois whoa
oh yeah
[Music]
right there you guys are really close
take care of this
let's get him back out there where's
that 209
why would you use the robot yeah yeah
Egypt
that is gonna make huge headlines on the
kid news kid news gonna write all about
it Lois
[Music]
Lois mom
whoa already handling inner turmoiler
Superman better than most I know
don't Mark Jimmy again
we have to go get Jimmy
[Music]
yes yes
that's cool
those fire department of metropolis
workers always saving the day
oh no
Maui owie in the face
so cool
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah new plan
oh the robots oh Jesus You're Gonna
destroy the entire city
oh damn
[Music]
hey
oh no
[Music]
keep it going
oh damn
[Music]
oh
can't shut me down
no
whoa
[Music]
that's the speed force Berry that's the
S stands for
[Music]
[Applause]
I was gonna land in like a building
somewhere we haven't thought of those
consequences yet yeah
I'm excited to hear Superman voice a
Superman
jokes
I'm sorry I lied you were right I was
being selfish oh when we showed this to
Perry he's gonna say this is garbage
what
what you brought me is a bunch of blurry
pictures of robots falling Lois was
right about the robots and we all stand
by the story we broke because we're a
team oh
we just have to get
an exclude interview with Superman and
then Mr White will have to take us
seriously that's your takeaway from all
this yeah
and forced him to tell us all his
secrets and then we'll publish them oh
Jesus
oh
how lovely that's fun and joyous Yes
siree slightly unhinged Lois Lane will
build into yeah yeah she finds
responsibility gleefully unhinged but I
like it I like it we're just gonna roll
right into the next one people get ready
to sync up episode two it's happening
it's immediately happened it's
immediately happened I like conspiracy
theory Jimmy Olsen too yeah
cool
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]
oh no
oh whoever
24601 that's right we needed to come in
early for some big surprise
say hello to our new office
sweet welcome to Freddy's Boiler Room
and sometimes mail gets sent here by
mistake
what
[Music]
I'm saying is ready and optimistic I
know what Superman is
you think he's a plane it kind of looks
like a bird no
taking this jacket Superman wore and
finding someone who can run his a off it
there are lots of stories we could bring
Perry right other than this one that he
hates
Fair Point
we are all laughing
spying yeah crime
damn
I don't know who you are so let's talk
City Bistro noon come alone or your Tech
is gone and don't order any appetizers I
won't be long I just want a latte they
should meet at bibos where is my Pivot
once we love him we can't be without him
used my powers to save people look they
don't know it was me but they know that
someone rescued them and now Lois
there's this girl Lois
[Music]
she wants to know more about him and I
want to know more about him too I need
to go back to the ship oh shoot I like
this we as in you and me are both
interns we're equals raise your hand if
you've been at the Daily Planet for
longer than Jimmy has
oh therefore I have seniority making me
a boss that was a loaded test right
there we
don't we'll find her speaking as your
boss I say it's worth the shot you'll
get there Jimmy don't worry I don't like
this John what's not to like about a boy
digging up his childhood spaceship
[Laughter]
that's the spirit
oh oh Fortress of Solitude that's a good
guess I found the boat Superman here we
come
uh or not
yes she left her boat taking the stolen
stuff with her so if we follow the
tracks it'll lead us straight to her all
right team Lois and Jimmy are
[Music]
who is that
wow did you take me from my mother
wait are you
[Music]
Daddy
oh
oh snap anime suit up yeah
[Music]
sweet don't worry I'm still me Ma I'm
still your son Nemo Nemo hey Naomi mom
but you're something else
lowest girl call you
fool Superman but
this needs something more underwear
[Applause]
I was a little bump she didn't make the
cape I'm glad she's making something
it's always been like a thing yeah her
making the cape's always been so like
whoa
[Music]
oh no
Ryden
I have no idea what kind of Technology
you're dealing with then I'd say it's a
good thing I planted explosives all over
the city and I'm ready to blow this
place Sky High kiss
what you talking about Willis
[Music]
oh jeez I said come along
whoa don't tase me bro you're right I am
Black Ops
and you're right
I am the smartest one here
whoa I see the Detonator you start
taking pictures I'm gonna stop the
explosives from going off wait Lois we
said
uh oh
there it is don't they
cheers I'm gonna stop the explosives
from going off I have to go love you
guys
thanks for the shorts
[Music]
being that there are also a lot of big
Mech suits and stuff I am getting like a
weird Metal Gear just like definitely
anime
yeah even that character design it's a
little metal Geary yeah I mean these two
yeah these two fighting right now
especially liquid snake
[Music]
no I like this both very much their
characters yeah and the Superman number
one
don't ruin my operation
I'll put a Target on my back you're a
jerk I think you put the Target on your
own back I mean you got one right there
TBH it's glowing it's a glowing Target
yeah there's explosives in the sewers
come on Ryden hit the turret on our back
oh hey he heard you
uh oh she's going Super Saiyan
oh no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no
[Music]
second time this week
cheers to hurt you
whoa alien Tech
oh
nice
are you okay
and now Superman
yeah you gotta minimize collateral
damage next boy
[Applause]
Amazo Tech I love that he's putting the
city back together because he's Superman
stop depressing
you did it boss hey
Lois
[Laughter]
I knew you'd make it happen you just
want it on the byline there was never
any doubt in my mind that you'd find
Superman because you Lois Lane
are extraordinary oh no and smart and
and funny and and smart said that
already well I stand by it no come on
you too ah
copy of tomorrow's paper Daily Planet
confirms the Superman is real we made
the front page that's tomorrow's news
today read the byline by cat Grant
Ronnie troop and Steve Lombard Steve
Lombard I know that name those
references cat Grant's a character I
missed the second name I was distracted
new plan failed now you're going to tell
us everything Nemesis Omega zero day
task force x tell us what no tell you
what a bunch of gibberish means task
force x huh tell us what you know
I have no idea okay I'm not lying the
flying man tell us what you know who are
you
unless everything you know about
Superman oh cool I like how they're all
like very serialized yeah like they go
week to week to week into the next
absolutely
this is and it's got like an anime
flourish without it like anime anime
like it's just the right amount you know
so we saw Amanda Waller who do we think
the guy is
good question maybe we'll find out in
the next episode right now uh I'm gonna
go okay it's Suicide Squad based either
dead shot or Deathstroke okay
oh
no starting with a vehicle in peril
that girl is everywhere she is on the
streets
it's like those kids in Game of Thrones
who keep eyes on people and tell Varys
what's going on
oh we saved Sully yes there's a fire on
the blimp we have to oh
yeah save kid news who are you just call
me
[Music]
comment gotta go take care of that blimp
oh come on not again it is a fiery blimp
in the sky I mean perhaps
prioritizes just saying
oh translucent no more anime characters
[Music]
[Applause]
Albert sis crazy lady give a stupid
powerful weapons we're busting you out
oh this is a mess amplify sound drop
your weapons and stand down huh no oh
oh
we getting some opening titles intro now
very anime inspired intro hope it's in
Japanese just for the intro yeah
whoa
whoa sweets cool
whoa poison coffee
grip tonight what's happening X-ray
vision
Louis are you okay
I'll be me and you pretend to be
Superman
I want to know more about you it would
mean the world to me if you let me
interview you if it was within my power
I would do anything for you Lois whoa
we'll see how easy that was
you're talking to the Daily Planet Star
News team sports reporter Steve Lombard
yeah gossip and human interest
if you can't say something nice darling
then come sit by me
oh come on Ronnie you gotta know who's
scooping them no
he thinks scoop means to steal which it
doesn't Steve it just means getting a
story before another reporter and I'm
scooping this oh geez no Harry assigned
us the Superman beat we'll make sure you
get an additional reporting credit when
we're done thank you system fails us I
thought those pictures would make Perry
seriously
beat the scoop troop and get to Superman
first scoop troop suspects have
reportedly used unknown Tech weapons to
escape I have to track down those
criminals and stop them I mean right
about them
this is the story we should cover we get
the scoop for the planet
what are we waiting for lead on
Smallville hey there it is oh okay the
last thing we got from the crazy lady
whoa
Zam they've looked down on us our whole
lives
but now we are about to get the respect
we deserve that's right also how to
convince them to let three interns talk
to the warden I can get us in but you
have to promise not to be upset
okay
yeah
[Laughter]
Siobhan's the leader of intergang a crew
of small-time crooks Rob convenience
stores
seriously anyways we were hoping we
could interview inmates investigate the
cell absolutely not I can't let the
Press walk through my prison she looks
like a Frank Miller character she does
what's
we can regroup
but the door is locked unless someone
had the warden's key card
oh wow Lois
oh
she's written down times oh why yeah
well fine where those imposters went
okay and bring them back here shoot
we gotta get out of here lucky for us
someone's already broken out we know
Siobhan wants to do something big but
what 4 AM 1pm or 5 P.M
your side
Metropolitan City make those times they
must be when Armored Cars come in with
cash transfers exactamundo
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh yeah
whoa that is a handy Robin tool let's
get
stay here at a sight where it's safe
I'll call the authorities and we'll go
get captured
capture that's when we'll get our
interview with him
oh no
[Music]
that was your chance for the well-being
of the people Metropolis I need
freeze everyone how about no
well we could even move Superman
it's not unlike the approach Batman took
when they fought
some sonic waves
[Music]
oh boy
oh she
got it
thanks bud
is there a line there
ah
not good at this
oh interesting
whoa no
what
whoa I'm not stopping at this rate it'll
overtake the whole city
yeah
[Music]
get some heat vision going that's how he
learns unlock your power
[Music]
oh
sweet
[Music]
[Applause]
whoa are these premonitions yeah what
does he keep flashing to
steamed I took out the machine causing
this but the people in the back got hit
hard they need to
need
no
anime villain
oh man
we can't find Clark oh where do I
about the interview
oh
oh I saw him phoning for help before I
flew in I understand you want an
interview Miss Lane oh Superman oh hello
oh Jesus what do you say we take this
interview elsewhere
oh dang I'd say hold on
[Music]
they're so cute they nailed that aspect
this is this is sweet well I agree to
this because when I told you and Jimmy
to save yourselves you stayed to help
others if you can face down a city
destroying freeze ray I think I can
answer a couple of questions
the truth is I'm still piecing together
who I am and what I can do but at the
end of the day I'm here to help the
people of metropolis that's what matters
absolutely and that's enough for a
satisfying story sound bite sorry
tell you my plan to interview Superman I
put you in danger because if
here on out I'll do whatever I can to
help you get that interview oh
wow
what'd you think of Superman oh he's a
liar
no oh that's great and yeah that tracks
all right
we got one more in this block people it
is interesting seeing them make
everybody Tech like Banshee going Tech I
didn't know if they would like keep her
that way we also still don't know what's
up with Amanda Waller and either
whomever
tune in to find out
I'm excited though yeah I like that
they're serialized so tightly he dodged
every question I
should know nothing that's
[Music]
Lois asked for them we're gonna track
down Superman by reading tabloids no one
normal believes in Aliens the truth will
be in these Lots
yeah together we can do this together
we will come upstairs with me oh
hahaha
fantastic however they make Perry white
like the anti-bat man just always
sneaking up on people it just appears
yeah so tonight I'm gonna give you a
shot
Dr Ivo CEO of Amazon Tech as in Amazon
oh we saw him in the ad he's throwing a
Gala for his investors tonight the cat
wants you three to get pictures of the
event and quotes about Ivo from the
people attending are we gonna get an
Amazo Tech monster you know amazing yeah
hi Jimmy have you uh seen Lois not yet
but look what I meant uh the planet's
entire camera room this is officially
lent you will definitely need a fish a
fish
oh
no
wouldn't we need the coolest light
whoo my wow
hell of the blushes the blushes are so
well timed the tech I'm about to debut
don't change anything you can't vote me
out of my own company okay I am Amazo
Tech and you are broke so listen to me
oh why don't you go ahead and keep the
board happy until the end of the night
Dr Ivo Clark Kent with the Daily Planet
I didn't realize reporters came in this
size but are you a linebacker think this
[Music]
oh between you and me I'd much rather
talk mono Amano
Ottawa motto you might have overheard
between me and Curtis we can introduce
you to the gala's fighter
bachelorette's quid pro quo
[Music]
or perhaps you want to comment on the
investigation into the fires that took
down your other competitors because I'd
love to talk about that
hey you know what let's just escort you
to the Press section
I tried and I don't even meet the dress
code anymore that we can fix take it off
I've ripped enough Blazers running after
stories that I'm always
yes
drink it in that's
small town physique grew up in a farm
does some hard labor
Daddy
Sam Lane oh I'm you can take it if you
need to no no it's fine he doesn't want
to hear about my screw-ups since I
started this job you have almost gotten
me fired
and smashed by robots do they not teach
you how to comfort people in Kansas
you've changed my life for the better
Lois I've been feeling off lately and
this means a lot yeah
actually there's there's something I've
been wanting to say something I Lois
it's a mislead
oh
sorry you were gonna say I uh
nothing
huh does he tell him to season finale
season finale that sounds like a good
bet I'll take those off up the stakes
for season two ah
blocked
um
stuck
Lois this is the same kind of stolen
Tech intergang hat
the baby
humiliated me but with this I'll shut
everybody up now turn me into the Green
Goblin make me Amazo I present the
parasite
parasaurus site good name why would you
call it that
we're in the midst of a crime wave like
nothing before
a stranger to help us for free
pay me to do it no one does anything for
free with the parasite you can become
your own
homes for men let's get a volunteer
whoa
whoa dude kind of demonstration is this
it doesn't be going well I expect to
make money this is taking too long let's
speed things up
huh hello hello
I don't know what's going on here but
you need to let these people go I don't
think you understand sales Alex
he's got the anime glasses yep
reflections of evil the parasite 1.0
gives me strength
s and durability
you know ow
and if he tries to fight back the suit
absorbs that kinetic energy and
redirection no black panther
now he has a tail
oh you're gonna have to get creative
Clark the show's
yeah help him out I built this
this
I deserve more
wow dude you're not gonna get what
oh
no I am not letting you interrupt
doctors
sorry your life
does UV light isn't just cool it can
reveal fingerprints
he's only ever used this one button yes
it's a brand new board
cheater
you cheated what do you think you did
dude this isn't a game you need to stop
you're afraid
but I'm better than you you got a
fragile ego boy a little bit a little
bit
[Music]
oh yeah
to be better than you I just have to
stop supplying you with power yes
[Music]
uh
that's gnarly the proof's all there the
stolen Tech which Ivo could only have
gotten from his criminal connections
once we get the photos we'll have our
story
who's pulling the strings Lois I have to
figure this out too many people are
getting hurt oh
you know when I was getting ready I kept
wondering if this comes it as a date oh
it does
what did you decide
[Music]
oh
what is this no
huh you gotta cleanly rip those pages
man
miracles in the heartland
[Music]
oh oh no
no that's right damn it
ugh
[Music]
did we pick the perfect episode
Cliffhanger oh my God I think we did it
wasn't the finale
sooner I shouldn't have taken that bad
dang well look what we accidentally
figured out hey well done nice detective
work Lois well done Lois oh my God what
up what a perfect Arc for first four
episodes such a delight man oh my what a
heartwarming show indeed sir so warm and
fuzzy yeah how you how do you feeling uh
liking it I um
the outro changes ever so slightly as
well
um I really think they've captured the
heart of Superman I really I've always
said that the one of the best things
about Superman is his relationship with
Lois uh a lot of very angry people were
like Lois Lane's casting doesn't matter
as much as Superman's when I kept saying
that it might be the most important it I
would argue is the thing that allows him
to be uh as Superman humanized like I'd
say monpaw can't help shape Clark and
then I think the anchor is Lois and to
some extent Jimmy so casting Lois is so
essential and uh I think the show more
than most really gets that Superman Lois
as well as Clark and Lois relationship
it's like really endearing they're
adorable uh the anime flourishes
sometimes bother me in anime like when
there's like the sweat beat or people
falling over and stuff like that but
they're using it in a more uh it kind of
works here like I like the over-the-top
newscasters like um rocket power like
that rocket power intro or the genuine
from uh Dragon Ball Z like there's very
much those elements but they're working
for me so um yeah it's a blast well
that's that's what's partly so cool
about their choice to make it in this
style because obviously I don't know a
ton about the production of this show
but it seems like uh something that
feels like an American production but
very much with authentic anime styling
sure um and I don't know what studio
does the animation or whatever maybe you
guys can Enlighten us but yeah I would
agree like I think this has the perfect
blend for me as a viewer of like it's
got some anime flourishes here and there
some of those yeah like little cartoony
or animation beats and things like that
where like eyes change or like a mouth
gets squiggly cartoony but in this
context and and again given that you
know it's like we're not watching a dub
of something we're watching something
that I think was always intended to be
presented in English and all that other
stuff you know it feels like the right
amount of anime without being like guys
we're doing an anime so um and the intro
being episode three I didn't see the
full anime influence until like you know
sprinkles but then the anime intro is
like it works for the show but it's also
more heightened yeah well and the lovely
thing to me is that this has kind of a
great blend of Like A Slice of Life
anime about you know people trying to
make it as reporters and and like a
sweet romance developing between Lois
and Clark but it also has a bunch of
your Superman action Orient stuff too
and it's at least so far a great kind of
blend of the two for me like I'm so
happy right now it's just Joy the score
does a lot of heavy lifting with like
pure happiness uh Jack Wade is so good
yeah and I mean like I I like I really
enjoy Jack Quay generally but going into
this I was like okay like there's a lot
of Jack Quade these days and so like am
I going to you know feel like I'm
watching a Superman thing or am I gonna
you know be mostly focusing on like oh
Jack wait but like I think he's so
lovely in the role like I love his voice
performance I love his take on Clark and
Superman and just like he's he does have
you he hear his voice and it does sound
like that you know kind All-American guy
you know who'd be a music fan of and I
didn't think of it before
Kansas yeah
of course it's Gotta Be
definitely an episode I didn't even
think of like wait a second yeah Kansas
yeah yeah uh I I also like like some of
the little tweaks they've done
um I don't know about making everything
Tech like Banshee and and live wire and
stuff but it works instead of like the
metahuman element they win Tech yeah um
but I I was so distracted by
Dr Ivo and Amazo I didn't think of Dr
Ivo obviously parasite so that was fun
for like that that combination of
elements I'm wondering if we still get a
meso because that's a character I like
think we'll get because of all the tech
but the parasite uh origin like the way
he looked which is more like the comic
book parasite after the tech suit I like
that we're playing with uh kind of like
Amazing Spider-Man did Tech that leads
to problems yeah Tech that that
irrevocably changes your DNA or whatever
and that seemed to be the the case with
Live Wire too because she had that you
know sort of cowl suit
yeah and then once it got you know
ripped off and the Crystal got destroyed
and everything like that it still seems
like yeah she's got this sort of
biological residual effect going on and
so yeah like it's I could see a version
where I would be taken aback by it being
so Tech heavy but at least as of right
now it seems like a theme they are
establishing and I will you know happily
give them the benefit of the doubt for
that I also like the overall Arc
structure where like they endear you to
the the civilian element episode one
episode two was like a Superman origin
effectively yeah and then uh you know
three is like the dynamic evolves and
changes before we get our first big
super villain like the all the pacings
really worked really well uh I do think
next we're gonna get something like
Jimmy Centric I think the way it ended
because we don't really have a lot about
Jimmy yet we just have the conspiracy
theory stuff we're slowly learning
things about Lois uh I really like the
use of mom podcast but I do think we're
gonna have like a Jimmy I think we need
to be endeared to Jimmy now because now
we've had the Fallout yeah exactly and
this leaves at least in terms of just
beats and stuff like that you know him
watching them walk away it makes for
what seems like a nice segue into a
Jimmy Centric story and something that
could maybe in the next episode you know
play to their friendship you know
because they've done so much to develop
his you know relationship with Lois and
the tension between you know them as it
regards Superman and all that stuff and
now she knows yes and then and I love
that they kind of spared no uh they they
didn't dawdle in getting to that I love
that we we're originally gonna do three
episodes and then last minute it changed
to four so I think it's really funny
that this was kind of like the first Arc
of the show like it literally ended
pretty perfectly yeah for where we could
have a commentary on it because I think
revealing he's Clark this early is going
to make for a really interesting part
two of season one Dynamic that I would
have assumed they'd save for season two
like it'd be like a big like oh and then
like everything changes but instead like
we're diving in quickly I'm I'm really
wondering with the changeover in in you
know the power structure of DC is this a
one season show did they know that when
they wrote it did they like is this
intended as a mini series because of how
early we find out like though now I'm
intrigued by those elements like does
this end in a way that feels like a
complete Journey yeah or will this be
sort of an else worlds among their many
things going forward and I feel like you
know if the response is good and there
are lots of viewers I could absolutely
see this continuing as its own little
else World despite the fact that they
have made the promise of like oh the
animation and the live action is gonna
be all consistent but then again Joker
and the Batman are separate so I guess
you know we could have a younger because
this definitely skews younger like this
is a younger toned show sure and I think
the anime aesthetic also helps to
separate it uh just from whatever I have
to imagine they'll have a more American
animation style for whatever the main
you know Creature Commandos and Waller
and all those other shows are
um but even still I mean it begs the
question because you do have a Waller
Presence at least so far you have had
task force x mentioned so yeah I'm
curious but at least as of right now I
mean I'm enthralled to a point where I'm
like I would hope it keeps going yeah
you know it's very joyous yeah yeah and
it just seems to capture that spirit
that just sort of like optimistic
hopeful Spirit that's not devoid of
challenge that's not devoid of you know
appropriately difficult or dark moments
or things like that there's Peril yeah
and I really loved what they did with
his Origins with uh the ship and uh
jorel and like we pointed out like the
language barrier that that represents
they didn't have a click and now you
understand him
or like some kind of like zoom into his
mouth and we Zoom back out in its
English or something
um but I love that like you know as a
boy he's kind of frightened to the ship
the whole thing is like a little
overwhelming yeah and then he comes back
and it's still this sort of mystery and
Ma Kent is like I don't know if you
should you know mess with that and paken
is appropriate like let's figure it out
I love that he learned that I'm just
gonna run away from Buckhead because
it's like the next scene gotta go yeah
that's so perfect yeah yeah and it's
like little things like that that make
the like mon paw haven't been on screen
a ton but like they feel present through
Clark yeah it's just such a lovely thing
and they go by mod pod can't I couldn't
believe the number of people I made a
video about Mom podcast because there
was a rumor that Brennan Fraser might be
paw Camp which I love yeah uh but I made
a video and I called him pocket and
everybody's like who's pocket and I was
like he's freaking Puck and everybody
was like you mean Jonathan Kent I was
like I do nothing
with Jonathan Don't Call Him Jonathan
that is Paul I don't know the man and
that is my ah well and then and then I
go to like one of the sons I go to
Superboy Jonathan Kent like yeah so I
didn't pause it he would have had to
have called him dad father Papa
something also if you say mom podcast
and it removes the Martha of it all in
our lexicon which is probably for the
best to separate so like monpa Kent is
who they are 100 and like I really
enjoyed just all the like little details
around I mean like you know you have the
Amazo thing which seems like it will
grow into something else but there was
like she has a Vicki Vale byline just
pinned to her wall in the first episode
I do feel like we get a big badden
parasite sure also we haven't had Alex
yet
no no mention of Lex Corp no Lex yet
nothing in that Tech area and I just
realized that'll be episode 10. yeah
that'll be the Cliffhanger of like oh
Lex Luthor this guy hates Superman yeah
maybe they'll meet and then it'll be
like that's the the prospective yeah two
is like oh dang maybe we're gonna have
to watch the sort of them learning about
each other forming their few rivalry I
love that we because I I I'm one that
likes the they grew up together like
I've always liked Clark and Lex growing
up together and then the Rivalry comes
from like him hating Superman then when
he realizes like I've always liked that
but that seems less and less the modern
pop culture take on on him so I'm really
curious if they go that way I feel like
they still could but they still could
they could be like oh that could you
grow up with yeah yeah he could show up
and be like Lex what are you doing yeah
look at Harry Osborne it yeah you moved
out of Smallville yeah now you're rich
and bald all that stuff but like the
blaming him for the baldness and
everything else it's always interesting
how that all goes and but like this show
can really go any direction I am glad
I've avoided a lot of the commentary I
haven't seen a lot of like images or
like oh my God this happened which is
nice
um I've been on the internet like one
tenth as much because of the strike and
I think that saved me a lot of spoilers
sure yeah yeah 100 no and I mean it's
been so nice to just go in knowing again
I I had an idea that this would be sort
of anime-esque and it's the Superman
story starring Jack Quaid and that's
that's about all I had and uh it's been
such a lovely just journey of Discovery
and and joy and and this take on the
character seems super classic but also
like it has this nice sort of fresh
Sheen about it yeah and yeah I just I
love the three of them I love the
dynamic they've established and I think
we've seen some of the animated movies
like you know a more
modern-ish take on Lois and I feel like
we've seen ones in some of the more
recent stuff even where she's like a bit
edgy but still has those lowest length
qualities and here I like that she is
like a rascal and she's always kind of
overstepping and you know digging for
the scoop and getting into trouble but
she does seem to have
like even though the character has some
kind of an edge she's not edgy in a way
that feels like it betrayed like she
still feels like that good-hearted
person who does just want to get to the
truth I am excited for her Arc to grow a
little out of the like
I'm doing anything for the story even
though I'm smarter than that yeah and I
and I do think that I mean obviously
it's a younger skewed show I'm forgiving
a lot but I am excited for I assume
that's what a worker is going to be is
becoming the Intrepid reporter she is
yeah but I didn't love the like just as
a fan I'm a huge fan of Lois Lane so as
the lowest Lane fan it's really hard for
me to see her even as year one reporter
being like this wouldn't work ever yeah
and I know I know that's the arc and
it'll change but that's my only qualm so
far is uh is Lois being like when they
go to the party I'm like you you gotta
know to finesse the situation you can't
just she gets a Pulitzer and I'm looking
forward to seeing that Arc she wouldn't
have interior one but I'm excited to see
that grow yeah totally but yeah I'm
having a great time at the show I'm like
that's my big qualm that's a tiny little
like it's a fun fun time and I'm really
enjoying the joy of it yes this is
Superman to me it's a really good time
and I love the score the the strings the
overall Vibe triumphant and swelling
yeah it's big it's a big score big big
big score well that is gonna do it thank
you all for reminding us constantly to
watch this I really enjoyed this one of
our most requested things I'm glad we do
dove in when we did what are we thinking
who we got uh David Gandhi the Paw Kent
of this channel he's been with us for
like I want to say he's one of our
earliest uh patrons out there he's been
supporting for such a long time and he
is a wise guy plus he's a photographer
so I mean Jimmy Olsen as well yeah a
little bit of Jimmy in there he takes
some really interesting photographs both
of uh you know landscape things and and
actually he does these like really cool
scenes with action figures and stuff
awesome so he's got the imagination he's
got the Mortal uh moral compass he'd be
friends with Clark and Superman very
helpful absolutely good Cornerstone well
we appreciate you very very much Mr
David Gandy that is our patreon shout
out for you we appreciate you very much
and that is gonna do it for this four
episode mega event of our adventure with
Superman we'll be back very very soon
hoping to get these caught up if you
like this leave a comment below if you
like this share it with your friends if
you like this hit that like button
itself Superman would he'd be a big fan
of the light I feel like Superman would
just like use his power to speed through
and like stuff we need a Superman she's
like every video every tube that wasn't
morally questioned yeah he'd like peruse
and understand what buzzwords were and
just click through you know Clark's
ready all right speaking of which you do
that hit that like button we'll see you
very soon for more Adventures of
Superman bye guys
[Music]